fantastic to be here at Charlie Park in
Clay Cross where we are doing the
groundbreaking ceremony for the new
brand new 23 million pound Clay Cross
active Leisure Center and Community Hub
it's been fantastic to see all of our
plans come to fruition we've been
working on this for the past two or
three years now in terms of building up
the case for it and then we got the
towns fund money the town deal money
from government to help contribute
towards it and then we've approved the
funding through the uh for through full
Council through the all the councils
agreeing to back the scheme and then
obviously gone through planning
permission and everything else it's been
a really long process but we're here now
eventually having you know getting
Spades in the ground and getting going
with the works and I know that a lot of
people in Clay Cross and the surrounding
area have been a bit concerned that you
know it's sort of all talk it's been
talked about for a long long time now
but finally we are here we are getting
Spades in the ground and we are
delivering this brand new 23 million
pound Leisure Center for Clay Cross and
the surrounding area and we all can't
wait to get in here next year when it's
opened up and and enjoy some of the
Fantastic new facilities that are going
to be on offer it's great to be here
today breaking the first ground on the
new Clay Cross active it's it'll be a
fantastic new facility for Clay Cross
and the threat surrounding area with a
new sports center but also new community
facilities well it's here at last the
day that we can actually put a spade in
the ground at uh Charlie park at Clay
Cross
we spent years planning this and there's
been huge consultation
we've spoken to a large number of people
especially the users about what they
want and what they think claycos needs
and I think that today marks the day
that we're going to deliver it so we're
also pleased to be here to do that